balers Gate 3 which I would argue is one
of the best games of the last several
Generations has just issued a brand new
patch that adds
3,589 lines of extra dialogue in a free
patch oh my God I already was
intimidated by how many lines of
dialogue there are in this game I can't
even imagine what their scripts look
like and they just added more and I
really wanted to give this a shout out
because patch 5 also adds a whole bunch
of new content fixes some issues and
also adds basically an entire playable
epilog the reason I want to sh out is
that that is so unheard of like the
patch is so beefy and bals Gate 3 didn't
come out that long ago like as a
side-by-side example it has taken
cyberpunk 3 years to do what balis gate
has done in a few months and I think it
makes a very good case for how useful
games being in early accesses